Hey Joe Rogan podcast by night,
all day he was sitting there was still
that kind of prestigious like app after
he lost that and it's like,
oh fuck it.
Yeah,
we can.
Coach
coaches were saying that his,
his own mma coach,
after he knocked out,
Brett Rogers said that fate or one with
his old tricks,
but he would have liked to have him for
more time training and he thinks he's
not,
he's not approaching it correctly and he
just won by being fader.
But he also caught,
oh,
uh,
for doom with that old trick.
He caught him,
knocked him down,
and then the mistake of federal members,
he jumped into his guard,
but remember he jumped into pound,
but he caught him really,
really well.
Knocked him down with the exact same
time that he did to everybody before
that.
So maybe maybe,
or maybe Verdugo goes down on purpose
the moment a punch him so he could drag
you into,
which he does.
He's a smart guy.
We're doing is a very smart guy.
Fight fights than Saturday.
Definitely did not face first because he
got tagged.
If you watch the stoppage,
if you see if you can find the
highlight,
I'll show it to you because this is
something that I wish somebody brought
up during the actual commentary.
He got tagged right before he got
knocked out.
He got tagged doing the same thing with
the right hand.
He moved forward.
He was making these advances.
He got tagged with that right hand and I
think he was on Queer Street and I think
he went running at steep a on queer
street and got knocked the fuck out and
the way they did it was a fucking work
of art.
The angle,
it was like Anderson Silva and forest
baby step to the right and even better.
His angle was sick and obviously his
right hand was nasty.
It's also volume did get hit early and
in boardrooms training.
If you've seen him train it,
there's this competition within that.
Jim,
when you get hit it's like,
oh,
got to get them back.
I think it was more gets hit and he was
like,
go charging bull.
And was like,
fuck this man.
I think it's probably a little of both.
I agree because I definitely think both.
He got crack crack and I'm like,
well that is a big right hand that he
got hit with and it's in the same
manner.
Same managed charging.
40 got hit.
That's how although got knocked out
against Mcgregor.
Yep.
You got to be fucking real careful
charging for
harder because.
And you know,
Steve Bay's not got some great guys,
but he's not a knockout artist per se.
If you compare them to like a mark
Nelson,
he's not knockout artist when the guy's
charging in like that and then you're
counting with right hand,
it makes it seem way.
Well here's my take on steep based
power.
I think Steve Bay has big power,
but I think he fights economically and
intelligently.
He's a smooth fighter,
a boxer.
He's a very good boxer,
a golden gloves boxer,
but he's smooth and relaxed in the way
he spars.
It's one of the things that makes them
so dangerous because as he does things
very correctly,
you know,
and I think,
DC was on the commentary for the UFC
recently.
He was talking about getting the rub,
you know,
he was talking about that experience.
When you have a tough fight with
someone,
you get the rub and he fought junior dos
Santos and they went to war.
What do you mean rubbed?
This is what I mean,
what he was saying.
He's like,
Daniel says,
when you fight someone that's really
good and they're better than you,
even if you lose you,
it elevates you.
You get the rub like just by sharing the
ring with them just by being in that re,
by competing with them,
you realize how good you are when you
actually get better and you realize how
good that person is.
Yeah.
I think he got the rub when he fought
junior dos Santos in a way because he
went five rounds with a guy who was the
one of the toughest of the tough guy was
at Warren,
a champion or knocked out Cain Velasquez
was one punch and he went five hard
rounds with them and the decision will
could have went either way and took his
best shot.
And I also think that to go back to
[inaudible] point and your point with
the rub,
I think at the UTC level of special
wouldn't get in that top echelon.
You know,
you're getting,
people are telling you you're good,
but like when he beat Orlowski starched
them.
You don't learn much from that man.
When he go up to a decision with a world
class guy,
then you know,
like you're doing something right,
your camp,
you're doing it right,
you had good gas,
you realize what works,
what does it.
So you learn so much more and he's going
to,
like you said,
more with jds and we see them getting
better and better.
What's really interesting now is here's
the dark horse that nobody talks about.
Stephan Struve is only 28 years old.
That fucking dude is gigantic.
He's seven feet tall.
And if he could put it together and he
put it together on big foot silver the
other night,
knocked him out.
I love the guy has a bunch of knockout
losses.
I know he does,
but he knocked out steepbank.
Struve got steeper
in the UFC.
Yeah,
dude,
Dude Struve do not count that guy out
yet.
Struve did an inside leg kick and then
he's got that heart issue and stuff.
Well,
I don't know what he's got going on
physically,
but I'm saying that kid,
if he puts it all together when you're
seven feet tall,
how long does it take before you even
get coordinated?
Right.
I mean it's like you're sending a
message and it's got to go so far before
it gets to your fucking hand.
I mean,
have you ever thought you fought guys
are super tall like Jack Man,
those guys.
I mean it like.
The thing is is steep aid would be,
or not Steve,
a strew would be such a fricking handful
of could learn to use his reach,
but you guys like Roy Nelson.
When you get these upper echelon guys,
you know,
nothing gets bigfoot but off trt or
whatever the case,
he actually needs it off it.
It's,
I think anyone that top 20 kinda them
up,
but with truth,
the real test of me who they give them
next,
that's true.
Got fucked up.
I over him and over and was joy
superintelligent.
Fight the way father,
it took him down.
Beautiful.
Take down on top of him.
Just ground and pound.
The thing about struve's,
you've got to realize that kid has I
think 40 fights.
Yeah.
Here's a shitload of miles now.
His heart,
heart and the mark.
What will have it does not.
No,
but it's.
I don't know what he's got.
What is the medical condition?
I forget.
We have the same manager,
so he deals with it all the time.
That Mark Hunt knockouts,
Jesus Christ Marco,
would that leaching left hook shattered
his face.
Oh Dude.
Mark on it.
So fucking you've been caged.
Sad scene that.
Oh,
it's fast.
Too
steep a can get.
I'm curious to see if they can get but
within boxing distance of allister and
take away any of those kicks and how he
sets it up.
It's going to be interesting.
Alster combox man.
He can't.
Oh yeah,
for sure.
Better than to tell you knocked out
junior with one punch.
That's good.
He's the best striker in the UFC
heavyweight division maybe of all time.
So.
So Steve,
Steve Bay,
then it's going to have to close that
distance and knocks him.
Not necessarily note Steve Bay could
crack him.
Look,
Ben Rothwell knocked him out in the
first round cup.
Has better fulfilled,
can happen.
Footwork and house has been stopped a
lot.
Chins the question.
This is the other thing people forget
with allister.
Then we'll fucking grapple.
Oh yeah.
In wrestling.
Grappling his ass off.
So you want to go to the ground with
them?
You're gonna be in a world of trouble.
Well he won the Abu Dhabi European
trials and in pride he submitted tour.
He's got an.
He also submitted Mark Hunt.
He has a nasty guillotine.
Dude.
His team always forgetting about
birthing of just as a striker,
but you want to go to the ground.
I don't think Steve Bay has a lot of
submission.
Work under is so steep and I trained for
two years together.
That kid has submission defense.
So you're not were shot as his black
belt.
If you asked Rashad to show you like
Omoplata a real specific,
uh,
offensive move.
It's,
I don't think at that black belt level,
but his defense and that's steep based
defense is nes super nasty.
It's just what?
He's really good at.
Defense.
He's a very smart athlete,
you know,
and it's when you have a guy who's a who
could probably be a professional ball
player,
right?
You Will Bay.
He could probably be a professional
ball.
He didn't make it.
Yeah,
he didn't make it.
He's at this level of an,
of an athlete.
Now.
What I'm saying is it's rare that you
see a guy like that who comes over to
mma and fights like super technical,
super smart,
who's also really,
really tough firefighter for
professional,
full time head.
His head is the biggest head I've ever,
ever seen into large set.
Nicest guy.
He's a great guy,
but he's.
He's got a rare set of attributes,
meaning that he's at pro sports athlete
level,
like as far as like like his,
his ability,
his movement and his intelligence in his
approach and his training and then on
top of that he's tough as fuck stuff is
tough as fuck.
Like in this fight.
Let me tell you something,
dude,
I watched this fight very careful and
one of the things that I was noticing
was how calm he was through everything
through the walk.
When they watch,
when they're staring each other down.
One of the things you really pay
attention to is the shortness of the
breathing.
If you watch people breathing during,
I'm like nervous situations.
A lot of times even if they look calm,
you could sort of see this uneasiness in
the way they're taking in oxygen.
You're sensing tension,
not seeing.
You don't sense any of that shit looking
at,
you know what's impressive to if he
doesn't come from like a mastermind
camp?
No,
it's just his boys and Cleveland.
Well,
he just might have a mastermind can be.
There's a lot of masterminds out there
that don't have the right pupils.
I'm saying he's not from like a
Jackson's Aka the att.
He kicks his shit within Cleveland and
does work and then goes and saves people
from burning buildings.
Who else is in that?
That camp is the guard style.
MMA.
There's also the.
Isn't there a Leslie Smith from there?
No,
it's not.
Raquel Pennington,
Right Jessica?
I'm Jessica.
I'm so.
They have tough fighters.
It's just like if a guy's like a really
skillful trainer and you know you've
only been doing it for a few years,
you have to wait for the right guy to
sort of walk through your door.
Then walking through the door with Eddie
Bravo with Eddie Bravo.
Took forever for him to find someone who
could do his style and prove in
competition that it's very effective.
Not just with him.
He had a unique style phase.
Brother or dad.
The guy with the mustache.
I look at that guy with a mustache,
guys.
Awesome.
Though.
You talked about being calm.
Remember he's fighting right now.
That guy's not that old.
Brian.
Why are you calling that guy his dad?
Because his older brother,
his older brother.
I guarantee it all.
Just some fucking thick dude.
You Know Eddie Bravo had a real good
point about this.
We were talking about on the phone.
He was like,
Fabrizio look too relaxed.
He liked.
He was coming up to the,
to the ring.
He was making that face that he may say,
yeah,
I'm so sick of that face.
Oh,
he's being funny.
It's being silly.
I don't think there's anything wrong
with a fighter trying to stay loose.
Don't at all.
You know.
I think that's one of the things that
fabrizio does to have a good time.
He likes to make that silly.
He's been doing it forever.
He's the man he's bullied for ever do
them.
If you won the fight and made that face,
no one say a fucking word.
If you went out there and head kicked,
steep meo chick,
you know,
no one would say a word,
but it didn't work out.
So when it doesn't work out,
that's when everybody comes shitting on
you.
It's the same.
What's the same with connor?
Connor?
Connor was walking out like,
you know,
same with Rhonda.
When Ronda lost everybody's mad at all
the shit that they loved her for,
they love to for don't be a do nothing,
bitch and fuck you.
I'm making it to the top.
Kiss my ass.
Or they hate it.
They now we think she's arrogant to
that.
Same with Canada.
If
he's in Venice right now,
driving around a royals Royce just
wiling out,
look,
I just,
you know,
it's just what comes.
It's part of what people love about
people bragging or they want to bring
you down though,
man.
Look how loose deep it looks because
loose.
I mean he's fighting for the title nice
and loose,
so he moves away.
Keeping argued.
He should've got title earlier too,
but he's like,
he's just such a nice guy and a lot of
checking to.
Lot of good checking of kicks,
a kid's ties.
Very good luck.
Very educated with his movements and
look for breezy.
Who's got some fucking nasty kicks man?
And he's like right there.
His striking is much improved.
We saw it in the Travis Brown fight,
man.
Dangerous on the feet,
Alaska is dude.
His striking is fucking legit.
He's long shit and he's got confidence
in it.
That nice switch kick there.
Yeah,
but he's a beast.
I think in order to be that dangerous of
a fighter,
you're going to have to open yourself up
a little bit.
Then when you fight a real strategic guy
like steep a,
you're to get a little bit of trouble.
Well,
I think what happened in this fight in
particular is that he forced it.
Yes,
thank.
He was in this gigantic soccer arena.
It's the biggest crowd in history and
mma in Brazil.
Look at that beautiful leg kick though
though.
Yeah,
the inside 90 Chad that to.
it's all nice.
Like the technique is real nice,
but I think for Breesa was just so
ramped up because there's all these
people in Brazil and I think he's a
confident man.
I think he thinks he's the fucking best
in the world.
He just has to get ahold of this dude.
There's a right hand and nailed the.
See,
so now we can take a shot tab.
But now.
But now look,
he's forcing it.
Forcing it because he landed it.
Yeah.
So Watch.
When he starts to force it,
he gets hit real hard and then he gets
hit hard and knocked out.
He tried that knee,
tries forward and when sees he got a
terrible single attempt there.
That was like such a.
you're like getting steeper on that.
He was also,
I mean he might've been just trying to
make them work,
but look,
maybe open up possibilities.
I think you dropped for a single mind.
Right?
And so he's not afraid to just be
writing their girls.
Not though be he's not reading range,
but he's real relaxed.
Even the waste throwing that chap,
that top,
top,
top now like he's economical and when
your economical and a five round fight
super chat.
I was a very nice legs by fabrizio.
He's timing that jasmine great inside
leg kick in.
The Jab also is super light.
Like he's just floating it out there.
Pop his nice lots of steps.
20 Jepson.
We stepped to the side there like that.
Like look at that jacket on sale like
that is to talk,
you know he's not,
there's no tension there.
You know what I'm saying?
Like it's like flowing a check that link
again,
nice leg kick by.
Steep.
A nice switch.
So right now for Mesa was realizing
like,
okay,
this is an easy part.
That's the one you're reading right
here.
Bang.
That's the chaos.
Now back it up again,
watch just just back it up just a little
bit to where it's chasing them.
So watching these channels,
he got rocky NBA players.
Really?
You're correct.
You're right.
I saw the correct though,
Joe.
I didn't see that until.
And he got mad and he came out.
Yes,
yes.
He got his tag.
Yeah.
He got tagged hard with that right hand.
That's right.
And then he kept charging and then he
got face planted with the second one
that,
that first right hand had him on Queer
Street.
I guarantee you because he's moving
forward and steep a drops it in on them
and it's the same punch he knocked him
out with and it's when when Steve Bay
throws a punch and this is how,
you know he's good at me,
obviously fucking good,
but this is how you,
you know,
techniques at a real high level.
His arm is like loose and then he throws
it and then as it gets to his face he
tightens it down.
It does this stack like as he's moving
away,
he's like,
it's a super efficient,
like really technical punch to the
throat that way.
Moving back back.
In that sense,
it's very much like what Anderson did.
Forrest Griffin.
It's also calculated because you threw
it twice and they both land and there
built.
You can tell they're working on it.
So he threw.
He threw the,
the,
the left hook twice to check,
right?
Yeah.
Moving back,
moving back and something as he stepped
into the side when he does that or you
had to guess it doesn't even necessarily
have to be that he planned it out and
that was a part of the game plan.
I think Steve Bay does that.
I think he's a really good striker.
If you look at his movie.
Yeah,
and I think you're looking at a guy
who's super fucking determined,
man.
Steve Bay is super determined and when
you're a guy that's that focused,
you're going to get fucking really good
at everything.
So after he gets that fight,
that Jab,
Jab,
it's like an upper customer.
It is too.
It's so everything he's doing is so
relaxed and efficient.
You don't see a lot of jazz for
Bluetooth.
Can you see a lot of jobs?
Like my all time favorite fighter?
Probably if I were to tell you who I was
most excited to see you fight is
probably vandelay phone.
Boom.
See that right hand?
Russian is fucking hurt here.
Yeah,
he got mad.
He didn't just get mad.
His legs jolted.
He had like you could see his legs
stiffen up when he got hit by that first
right hand.
He got hurt and then the second one face
plant some steep.
Pays a dangerous guy.
He's not going to make mistakes.
They Cleveland.
Let's get our boy a goddamn parade.
No one.
When Shit.
No Shit.
He.
Lebron.
You want a jacket?
Real other UFC fighters.
How would you tweet out about steepen
your boys from your home town.
He jumped off the fence.
He goes,
I'm the world champ,
the world champ.
He was like,
it was like coming into his,
his,
his mind like,
is this real information?
Hey Lebron.
Did that just fucking game of fucking.
Yeah,
I love it.
I love that man.
I love him.
I love what he stands for.
I love watching him as a fighter.
I love that he could do that.
I love it.
I love that he did it in Brazil.
Look at this.
Watch this.
Watch how fish.
Stupid.
See it's pink.
Oh yeah.
He just dropped it in,
um,
to,
to be able to time it that good to look
at this.
Watch the timing.
He pushes his hand away and then put the
same hand.
Did you see overeem?
Overeem's tweet and crack.
Yeah.
He wants to fight him.
You said your neck and he did the
bloodsport me see that?
That one showed both that.
That highlight right there was the
perfect high left to the right because
it showed the first one that how much
impact the first one had on them.
The first punch was a big factor there,
man.
That first punch had him.
Cole.
Weird up.
Unbelievable man.
So cool.
I like that.
You could still say Queer Street and
you're not a homophobe queer streets.
Fun.
It's just strange.
You know,
like what,
where am I at?
The heavyweight division is
fun right now,
man,
because I don't think we're gonna see a
champ.
Rain for a long time.